sinon qu'est-ce qu'on range bourrignon
revisitée je vais pas faire la cuisine
fallait le dire mais non c'est la bouche
du futur ça fait dix ans dans la
nourriture de demain semble être le
nouveau dada des innovations high-tech
en même temps avec près de 9 milliards
d'humains à nourrir un réchauffement
climatique qui s'emballe et des
ressources en eau douce limité on ne
peut pas vraiment continuer à produire
du boeuf et des légumes à grands coups
d'eau et d'engrais innover en matière
alimentaire semble donc être une bonne
idée
c'est ainsi que ces dernières années ont
vu naître un nombre phénoménal de
solution miracle
notamment pour produire des protéines
l'exemple le plus courant ce sont bien
sûr les insectes et les verts ils font
déjà partie du repas dans certaines
cultures et le fort rendement de la
production intéresse sérieusement les
industriels avec dix tonnes d'aliments
on peut produire 9 tonnes de protéines
d'insectes alors qu'on ne produira que
une 1,5 tonne avec les bovins et les
porcins ou la volaille certains
préfèrent miser sur les algues comme la
spiruline qui croît de façon naturelle
dans les eaux chaudes salées et
ensoleillé mais les protéines et les
vitamines qu'elle contient restent plus
difficiles à assimiler pour l'homme
autre option beaucoup plus cher le state
in vitro
il s'agit tout simplement d'un amas de
cellules musculaires qui se multiplient
dans des boîtes de pétri avec un milieu
de culture suffisamment riche contenant
notamment des hormones des facteurs de
croissance des antibiotiques et les
fongicides mian autour de 1000 euros le
gramme ce sera peut-être le caviar du
futur mais ceux qui ont le vent en poupe
ce sont les repas en foudre équilibré
facile à produire et rapide à manger il
se présente comme une solution
alternative au repas traditionnel
c'est le fantasme de l'aliment miracle
qu'on nous sert depuis des années en
science fiction et et c'est d'ailleurs
en référence au film soleil vert qu'en
2013 la première marque américaine de
repas à boire choisi son nom dans ce
film mythique les ressources sont
épuisés et les humains se nourrissent
d'aliments de synthèse que silent
fabrique à partir de cadavres euthanasié
donc un choix marketing audacieux mais
bizarrement aucune de ces solutions
alimentaires miracle n'a connu de succès
vraiment retentissant
ces aliments du futur sont en fait des
aliments
descriptif un concept inventé par
l'anthropologue industriel fanny parise
pour désigner ces produits qui étaient
jusque là absent de notre culture
alimentaire et qu'on nous propose
désormais de manger par le biais d'une
innovation technologique sociétale ou
marketing
et forcément ça crée de nombreuses
résistances en premier lieu une part de
la population refuserait de tester ces
nouveaux aliments simplement par
néophobie alimentaire
cette réticence à manger des aliments
inconnue est un trait commun de
nombreuses espèces d'omnivore et serait
à l'origine en comportement de
protection contre les empoisonnements où
les intoxications alimentaires
aujourd'hui certes nous connaissons
mieux notre environnement mais nous
développons une défiance de plus en plus
grande envers l'industrie alimentaire
en réaction notamment à de nombreux
scandales sanitaires au delà des besoins
énergétiques ce qui va influencer nos
choix d'alimentation
c'est le plaisir de manger et surtout la
perspective du plaisir qu'on aura à la
dégustation d'un aliment en 2015 le
neurologue serge hulk et son équipe ont
montré l'implication de deux types de
voies nerveuses dans la régulation de
l'alimentation chez les mammifères
un premier réseau de neurones qui va
répondre principalement aux besoins
énergétiques
j'ai la dalle et je mange et un deuxième
réseau de neurones essentiellement liée
au plaisir que procurent la nourriture
c'est ce deuxième réseau de neurones qui
va guider une partie de notre attirance
pour ce qui est beau et bon c'est aussi
lui qui est responsable du comportement
que l'on appelle comfort feeding le fait
de manger pour se réconforter de façon
totalement déconnectée de ses besoins
alimentaires
l'aspect autant très le goût ou l'odeur
joue donc un rôle clé dans notre
décision de manger ou non un aliment et
on ne peut pas dire pour l'instant que
ce soit très réussie pour les repas en
poudre ou les protéines de synthèse
au delà de prendre du plaisir à manger
et de nourrir notre corps prendre un
repas nourrit aussi et surtout le lien
social
le repas collectifs chez les premiers
hominidés était un élément nécessaire à
la survie en groupe
il permettait de partager le gibier avec
les plus faibles et de favoriser la
communication au lieu de la compétition
pour la nourriture
aujourd'hui notre repas ne détermine
plus notre survie par contre la
commensalité donc le fait de partager un
repas avec des convives reste un moment
fort de sociabilisation
après tout c'est vrai qu'on retrouve à
travers les siècles et dans presque
toutes les cultures des repas pour
célébrer les moments importants en
communauté qu'est ce qu'on fait pour les
fêtes quelle que soit la religion on
mange et qu'est ce qu'on fait pour un
anniversaire
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour un mariage oui
c'est pas faux on boit aussi mais
l'alcool ce sera pour une autre fois en
attendant c'est pas pour rien que les
cuisines de l'elysée ou des ambassades
se paye des cuisiniers trois étoiles
c'est une question de diplomatie
[Musique]
et ça date pas d'hier puisque à
l'antiquité aussi il y avait une
dimension sociale or par pourrait
totalement c'est une dimension sociale
en effet politique il faut pas perdre de
vue que l'antiquité c'est l'antiquité
grecque par exemple c'est une très
grande période de temps sur une très
grosse aire géographique yves wehrli sur
les siècles et c'est donc les pratiques
aussi elle varie elles sont différentes
en fonction des cités en fonction des
époques dans les cités mais globalement
le banquet notamment le banquier public
le banquet civique c'est vraiment un
moment oui de des changes politiques ont
fait circuler les idées il y a suivra
encore une fois les sites et les moments
une codification avec les rôles des
citoyens plus riches qui font six ou
sauber dans d'autres cités c'est tout le
monde c'est un signe d'égalité de
partage entre tous citoyens et voilà et
ça a évolué au fil du temps se battre
tout le temps partout la même pratique
mais clairement la dimension sociale
aussi d'éducation du jeune citoyen ou
c'est un rituel aussi
tu apprends à te comporter en société
donc on n'est pas du tout wazifa à boire
et manger tous cochés qu'enfin il ya ça
dans le banquet évidemment ça c'est
clair mais après aussi les sacrifices où
on partage la viande la viande commune
et puis plus tard dans le temps
d'antiquités plus tard par exemple
plutarque lui il est saoulé par les
banques et civiques et tout c'est trop
m'as-tu-vu c'est un plus à rien pour lui
donc ils préfèrent les onglets plus
petit comité
chez les privés donc oui dimension
politique sociale mais qui évolue le 16
novembre 2010 le repas gastronomique des
français est la première des traditions
culinaires enregistré par l'unesco sur
la liste du patrimoine culturel
immatériel de l'humanité
et ce n'est pas simplement le repas
entrée plat dessert qui est distinguée
mais une vraie pratique sociale je cite
un ensemble de rituels et de valeurs
avec en premier lieu celui du partage
alimentaire le repas gastronomique met
l'accent sur le fait d'être bien
ensemble le plaisir du goût
donc si cette distinction internationale
a un goût si particulier pour les
français ça n'est pas seulement parce
qu'elle récompense leur amour immodéré
pour la bouffe mais parce qu'elle
reconnaît la vertu sociale dure pas et
se partagent alimentaire prend désormais
une autre dimension à travers les médias
sociaux
et oui le foot porn auquel certains
s'adonnent sur instagram a aussi une
fonction sociale basée sur le partage de
photos appétissante
oui donc elles font appel à notre
circuit neuronal du plaisir le football
nous permet d'élargir l'espace de
convivialité
au delà des proches qui partagent notre
repas vers ceux qui ne peuvent pas être
avec nous mais aujourd'hui dans les pays
développés les régime alimentaire
particulier se multiplient sans
allergènes sans lactose sans gluten
végétarien locavore bio vegan cacher
crudivore sans porc hyperprotéiné
chronobiologique macrobiotique certes
adopter une alimentation particulière
n'est en soi pas une nouveauté dans la
grèce antique par exemple ça
un groupe de pensée adopter un régime
alimentaire spécifique les
pythagoriciens par exemple était
végétarien mais aujourd'hui les régimes
particuliers sont très hétéroclites et
relève d'un choix individuel ils peuvent
être de simples restrictions médicales
mais sont souvent le fruit de prises de
positions idéologiques religieuses
politiques ou même d'une défiance envers
l'industrie agroalimentaire évidemment
ces nouvelles pratiques alimentaires
complexifie mêmes remettent en cause le
principe de la commensalité en créant
une exclusion volontaire ou non du repas
partagé
en étudiant l'intégration des
particularismes alimentaire dans les
repas la psychosociologue estelle masson
et l'anthropologue claude fischler note
une grande variabilité entre les pays
anglo saxons et les pays latins aux
états unis au royaume uni et dans les
pays du nord de l'europe
on aura tendance à satisfaire
intégralement les exigences alimentaires
sont jamais les remettre en cause et en
proposant à chaque convive un plat à des
côtes en france et en italie l'idée est
plus souvent d'ajouter quelques plaques
compatible avec les régimes particuliers
mais sans changer le plat principal
partagé par la majorité
peut-être que dans le pays du repas
gastronomique manifesté une exigence
alimentaire revient à affronter une
pression sociale plus forte
autrement dit à assumer d'être le chien
ou le chef de service au final dans tous
les cas l'idée de préserver l'apparence
d'un repas même si tous les convives
n'ont pas mangé exactement les mêmes
aliments et cela laisse entrevoir ce à
quoi pourrait ressembler le repas du
futur probablement pas un repas en juin
mais plutôt à une sorte de pique nique
partagé ou d' apéros dînatoires dans
lequel chaque convive pour à picorer ce
qu'il veut merci d'avoir regarder cet
épisode du vortex j'espère que vous
n'avez pas trop faim n'hésitez pas à
laisser un commentaire
abonnez vous et rejoignez nous sur le
discorde
et puis je vous dis à très vite à
[Musique]
ça va être dégueulasse le futur mais si
tu as raison ça va être dégueulasse